Good morning, Hank, it's Monday.
I woke up early on Queen's Day here in Amsterdam,
because Henry was all like, "I don't always
wake up at 5:42 in the morning, but when I
do, I expect to be fed." The Yeti and I dressed
him in a Dirk Kuyt jersey and headed down
to the Voldelpark that morning. The streets
of Amsterdam were abandoned and only ducks
were on the canals although the port-a-potties
in the distance hinted that a party was brewing.
As we walked we passed this Emily Dickinson
poem "To make a prairie it takes a clover
and one bee, / One clover, and a bee. / And
revery. / The revery alone will do, / If bees
are few."
When we got to the Vondelpark, families were
already setting up their stations for the
freemarket, which is so called because none
of the items in it are free, not even the
back issues of Donald Duck comics.
Queen's Day is a celebration of Queen Beatrix's
mother's birthday, and it involves this strange
city-wide garage sale where people sell artwork,
and old clothes, and unicycle with hula hoops
for tips, and offer carnival games, and oh
my God to be kid on a lake in a bubble. It
was pretty great, but Henry just wanted to
play in the sandbox. He was like, "Guys, look
at this stuff! It is AMAZING."
After a while we walked back to the apartment,
and I watched thousands of people streaming
downtown. And then I met up with nerdfighter
Tobias who was the only person in all of Amsterdam
not wearing orange.
Tobias: I looked in my wardrobe and I didn't
have anything orange.
John: You're embarrassing yourself.
John: I'm starting to feel a little anxious.
Tobias: Why?
John: Just because of the number of people
who are here and also wearing orange, which
is very anxious color for me.
There were no more ducks in the canal and
no more empty streets, just a lot of people
and free inflatable hats.
John: Now that we've got these hats, it's
definitely a party.
Tobias: Yeah, it is.
We finally made it down to the museumplein
where a hundred thousand drunk people were
listening to music, whereupon Tobias tried
to teach me how to say "Queen's Day" in Dutch.
John: CO-nin-nin-nin-dag
Tobias: Koninginnedag
John: Ko-nininachdach
John: Ko-ni--
Photobomber: Koninginnedag WAHHHHHGH!
We got photobombed quite a lot down there
in the museumplein.
On the walk home Tobias and I had an impassioned
discussion in RE: the providence of this liquid,
and then he bought a biography of Elton John
at a free market.
John: We just saw a guy trading underwear
for Rice Krispie treats. Which is the kind
of thing that, like, does happen, but not
at 2:20 in the afternoon.
Finally, after an hour of pushing through
crowds I made it home. Techno was rattling
our apartment, but I was happy to live in
a world that finds cause to celebrate. And
happier still that, by law, the party ended
at 9 p.m. That's just good government regulation
at work, Hank. I'll see you on Wednesday.